yeah exactly everyone wants
gochafu let's see what she goes for
she's going to be the baltic
all right and the prophet
wow now you know what to do against this
i think she does knight c6 and there's
this trap where
what black quickly puts it puts her
knight on b4
and e3 in this position would be a very
bad blunder due to knight b4
i think he's going to play bishop g5 i
think he's going to publish with g5
bishop
he has to stop that threat
does he he normally plays bishop g5 um
yeah wow the prophet would be a good
move
this is definitely my field i mean it's
not the london but it is a similar to
bit
position so finally a d4 game for me
feel comfortable i like the fenton is
thinking here he recognizes that there's
some minefields and he takes
will she play knight b4 anyway we talked
to
yeah then then white has e4 i think we
mentioned this possibility
yeah he needs to develop his bishop and
i and i think he will he very rarely
plays e3 e3 would be a
bit of a bit of a slip yeah and there is
and he does
so he told me that
in our first lesson he plays london
queens again but i was like that's great
just keep doing that like that's a very
solid opening repertoire
i have not talked i agree even though
actually i heard you talking
badly about the london on the last
pogchamp
commentary you were doing so oh yeah i
had to defend myself
and let me again backtrack blame
yourself here right right so so i
i played the london i played the
trumpowski i like i like the dark
squared bishop going to f1 g5
but i was falsely accused i was
slandered
of teaching all the pog channels
participants to london i am not eric
rosen
i understand we're both international
masters but we're different i promise
right daniel you're a gm absolutely
uh they they don't confuse you with
other grand masters named daniel how
many grand masters in the world are
named
i have played another grand master named
daniel daniel compora
there's also daniel king who is a very
prominent commentator
mean you um luke mcshane here with a wig
advantage
i don't know andrea how's your
impressions game can you do impressions
no not even well honestly i have no idea
who you guys are even
do an impression of right now but
nobody heard that you know let's say
international master olivia roseman is
very good at peter lecko you know
uh peter roleck has been doing a lot of
commentary peter
what can you tell us about this position
oh man
uh uh i don't i don't know what you're
talking about no um
i'll save it i'll save it i'll save it
because i feel like we're gonna leave
andrea out of this and i i feel like if
you and i just go kasparov lecko
what's andreas just gonna feel i guess i
don't watch too many of their live
you know who gary kasparov is right yes
i don't listen to him talk too much but
i'm definitely familiar with his
gameplay
see yeah we'll save we'll say some of
the impressions
well bishop g5 daniel you're uh you're
not gonna get a prophet highlight this
bog champs just yet
uh but it's
it's it's still on the horizon
potentially potentially yeah i mean this
is
this is a solid position but big props
to
uh easy with aces he responded very well
to that
tough tricky opening he's gotten a very
very solid position here and he shows
uh ability knowing how to play e3
developing his bishop so
very well done once again he definitely
has the advantage with the bishop bear
i i'm hafu i don't think she should have
allowed the bishop g6 trade
to try to save a bishop make room with
it maybe with an h6
wow i keep saying wow but these players
are really really impressed they are
they are just flat out impressive wait i
have a question if bishop b7 is 97 here
the best move
because queen e7 is there is there a
knight d5 i think there might i mean you
could take on e7 allow knight t5
and then shift the queen over but i
think that's very dubious i think you
should take with a knight
if she plays knight takes e7 i i i i got
nothing
she might be a better player than me
okay mistakes are still possible she is
still human
though fenton also blundered the rook so
anything can happen
hey well disrespect my my students
our students are battling so we're both
had to head here
uh you did way more lessons with with
hafu than with finton
this is this is territory war what this
is this is for group b dominance
please play knight takes d5 finton
please it's just a free pawn
please don't be afraid of taking free
pawns i mean you could also develop the
bishop here
white is still better if you play bishop
d oh he takes the knights oh
no maybe he just didn't see it
oh i think he m just realized
no you know what the dangerous thing
about this position
is that if she plays that move which she
just played
and now she has a pretty nice attack
yeah this could get
really bad really fast the bishop can't
develop itself because
g2 is going to be hanging
yeah i don't know where he's gonna be
able to castle his king's kind of stuck
in the middle
the best move might be something really
obscure guys it could be something like
queen bee one everybody really
or queen d3 just the train the
developers
oh my god how are you going to go into
your lounge and then play a move like
bishop d3
vincent that's really cool though i have
to say that setup is really cool
look at that fireplace
i'm disappointed i mean you go you go to
the fireplace you're supposed to stare
at
you know the at you know the flames and
cultivate good thought you just
bust out bishop d3 and snap yeah i'm
curious if it was like the mindset
because after
he played knight takes knight he started
talking very rapidly so he may have
realized he missed the free pawn and got
a little bit down on himself
and now everything starts crumbling you
know yep
this honestly feels like fighting thanos
is what this feels like
that like you you just get something you
know
for for the movie to have like a tense
moment and then just like
done queen takes g2 she's going to play
rook takes h2
you know one indicator that you're good
is not only your good moves but your bad
moves aren't that bad
and we see here that even hafu's
mistakes are by and large in the grand
scheme of things they're minuscule
let's put up hafu speaking of thanos
let's watch
look at that look at that humility is
this throwing sense i know
highlighting the best move on the board
i know
she really needs to chill out now i mean
it's getting my ears are hurting
she's very cautious i think i mean the
screaming is just
a good run yeah
it's like when tf blade was like i don't
know dude i was just trying i don't know
the feeling is throwing 95 accuracy but
then all these pieces are there
maybe i can just castle this way i
wonder when she's scared i told her not
to be okay
yep that's that's definitely something
she struggled with at some point she i
think she's gotten much better at that
and here we see she has
okay queen b3 white is still in the game
yeah wait hold on hold on we still got
half on the big screen
he said i don't know and played the best
move i wish my life was like that
i don't know best move i don't know am i
throwing
best move you're like magnus that's like
magnus yeah
okay yeah literally yeah it's not like i
lost him earlier today
yeah how could you danya uh losing
horrible
unacceptable i'll get my revenge on him
one day
okay so he didn't see queen b3 he's
playing defensive here okay so now
if i go up if i take
oh she's speaking takes that take he
takes it's not good right
she's skipping his turn that's a new
level of disrespect
you just said if i go up and then i take
i mean does finton not get a move
right no she thinks white doesn't move
i can start attacking this one
i feel like i'm gonna throw i mean here
she has many good options she could
castle trade rooks knight before
he's gone rook h1 very sensible trading
a pair of rooks
how does she see everything this is
crazy it really does it's crazy
it is crazy i was basically going to
repeat exactly what you said lovie
that's it i realized yeah but i was
independently going to say the same
thing just add a caspar of like
accent in there and child will love it
but halfway i mean you know hafu really
sees everything you know
it's quite uncanny reminds me of myself
you know when i was 12 years old
wasn't he like 2512. it was like
formally new is 2200 but i realistically
knew my playing strength you know is
almost as good as hufflepuff bro you
your kasparov
is like the greatest queen thing
ever thanks i that's how i entertain
myself
in very well like you see the shower
yeah when i'm walking around making food
oh my gosh okay truly be a good chess
player you have to get in the character
too
absolutely i can go there
get it back on the big screen here not
too much happening rook h1 clinical move
there the only thing that could happen
here is that hafu disconnects uh
she is just playing lights out chess
she's probably gonna play rook h8 rook
h1
and i think it's very unlikely that she
disconnects
but i'm not
not saying i'm cheering for that what
i'm saying is that's the only way that i
think finton is going to
gotcha gotcha yeah this is
uh he seems to have gotten a little bit
more comfortable
and a little bit more confident as well
incredible definitely
still not over only two pawns up and in
the grand scheme of things
that is a surmountable advantage but not
the way that hafu is playing right now
yeah a great thing about hafu is many
times when players start
winning they get too confident right and
then it's easy to throw but
she never lets the confidence get to her
she stays focused even
how winning she is yeah and this is this
is the tough thing about defending a
position you play e4
suddenly your center falls apart this
knight now has a new target
if she plays knight takes d4 here she
should be in the next
invitational world cup i mean olympiad
yeah this is
somebody said we've got a chat pro i see
this she's up but confused with no plan
she's got a plan she's she definitely
has a plan
she's just saying she doesn't have a
plan i mean oh yeah she always doubts
herself
that's one of my favorite emotes that
finton has chat pro
thumbs up yeah
well you should you should check it out
she just takes on e4
uh even if she accidentally blunders
with bishop e4
knight takes d4 she still wins the queen
back
if somehow she doesn't see this
yeah i think she intends to give a check
on g5
and maybe bring the queen to f6 that
would also be solid and strong
while she's calculating it oh my gosh
she might play knight t4 no she might
play knight d4
that's incredible she oh okay get out of
town she's really gonna know
she was hovering over it she sees them
both she sees both lines
mine
still a perfectly good move wow
why isn't she playing on an olympiad
team
exactly definitely could she has a
dedication for it
she literally could represent
some some some of the players uh
incredible
i don't think i've ever seen improvement
fast and i'm not just saying it
really improvement faster than her arc
unbelievable especially if she takes the
pawn right now
which she can still do yeah she plays
knight takes d4
i'm falling off my chair she's looking
at it
yes she is she's hovering over they're
just so sharp man
drum roll please wow oh my land
oh my gosh what did you just say that's
a north carolina expression oh my lands
where'd you pick that up when did you go
to north carolina
well when i moved to charlotte that's
when i picked it up
i didn't know that i don't think they
speak like that in charlotte i've been
to charlotte i don't know
yeah no not quite but oh my god 45
minutes out of charlotte
and you'll see her that expression okay
kona and there there are some
tactical tricks here for example you can
play bishop takes b7
check and if king takes b7 you can play
queen e4
and hope that now that your queen is out
of danger
you can take the queen for free but
black has queen d5
and your dream is ruined
no room for tricks
yep and the thing is if finton takes the
queen and hafu recaptures
then after the king moves to add insult
to injury there's knight to g3
forcing the trade of bishop for knight
which is in black's favor
wow wow this is
this is yeah this is crazy
crazy
what does she play now i'm sorry well i
guess like
finton has to decide where he's gonna
put his queen
yeah maybe c4
c yeah c4 is
an interest interesting try he doesn't
have i don't know he doesn't really have
any plan of attack but
i guess just aim towards b7
we could listen into finton see what
plans he's looking for yeah let's do
that
let's listen to fenton yes gets out of
the discovery check and protects this
check square
i don't see like i don't see like a
multi-phase plan but
every time we listen in oh huffy is
gonna have to move her queen
just have a little oversight just forget
about the queen hafu
the prophet spoken again with queen c4
yeah that's a good move it keeps some of
the tension on the board i mean it's
just
definitely better than trading the
queens going straight into the losing
game
what about this check
take nope because of this
if we go to the square searching
desperately for any counterplay
that is not a fork rookie one threat and
special takes b7 check that might be the
best practical chance take this piece
i calculated rook d1 but i don't think
he thought about rookie one
it's just a nice move isn't it just
protects against his pawn as well
playing very well i would say oh we're
we're back but
uh rook e1 if rookie one bishop b7
actually happens that would be
astounding that would be the comeback of
the day
yeah i have a feeling the rookie one
huffu would anticipate the
the attack on the queen mover king or
something
perhaps move her own king to b8 slide it
off the light square
yeah i don't think she'll fall for but i
don't want to jinx anything so
yeah it's not like any of us jinxed
anything in the previous game so
okay so there is no rick
yeah now she can get in with the queen
right that's going to be the problem
we need to we're even queen e3 check
yep
and wow
yeah this is uh this is curtains my
friends
uh because if you play something like
king b1
well no i was about to go big brain mode
and suggest
queen e4 and that a classic
motes gambit very nice uh yeah with a
smothered mate
right yes um
yeah i think queenie two is is likely
queenie two just the trade
yeah i think well there's many moves
here i mean
she's fully aware of that principle to
trading when you have material
she could also just you know even drop
her knight back to e6 that's also
totally fine
and maybe try to make room to bring in
the the rook
this is
she's just going to watch her clock
knight f5 is an excellent move now
notice that f7 is actually not hanging
because of queen to d3 check picking off
the rook
amazing the queen is stuck defending so
would would queen up see so here's my
question obviously she wow she's like
very much
chill leaning back in her chair um
is is she
seeing that on queen f7 there is queen
d3
i think so yeah i don't think she's too
worried about
the most important defender here leaving
wow
okay bishop e4 yeah because if she saw
it wasn't possible well then that's
that's that's that is brilliant
bishop e4 is losing guys because of the
knight forks
knight g3 and knight d6 i thought as
well right yeah okay
even better even better yeah it's about
gg now
it's unbelievable and now queen takes c4
or knight takes c4 both moves are good
she's got enough time she's gonna just
play like c6
the professional move oh absolutely
yeah the cautious player she is i
anticipate something like c6
right and you just see this because the
queen and the rook goes straight down
yep queen and the rook are biting on
granite and she's done it like
look when a player is playing 90 of the
moves that like we
are suggesting yeah exactly exactly he's
insane
unbelievable uh i listen i look forward
to the playoffs
i really look forward to the playoffs uh
this
we've had so many different personality
skill levels obviously
in the first in the first go around with
pawn champs we kind of knew we want it's
like it was like golden state
and and and cleveland for basketball you
just like charles barkley said you
pretended you didn't know
what you knew it was gonna happen and
in this one oh wow she plays 92 she even
play queen takes rogue
i think she wants to take it with
checkmate i think she's seen it and she
wants to send the king over to a1 first
unbelievable that
who do is think is going to be hafu's
best competitor
what is wagga's like rating right now
he's like 1400
oh wow okay that's going to be an
incredible matchup then
he's higher rated but she definitely
plays that level
and we are it's official we have
checkmate on the board
uh it seems like some
she's had some crazy crazy fights but
she is uh 4-0
she has won every game that she's played
uh we are gonna take a quick break
get the players in on the call and have
interviews don't go anywhere
hafu and easy with aces will talk to us
in just a moment
welcome back everybody we're joined by
hafu and
mr finton easy with aces we were just uh
chatting before we
went live uh first of all congrats to
hafu uh
i'll start with hafu actually anything
surprise you about this match anything
you know
was the what were you expecting how did
it go differently than maybe your
expectations
oh well people said it was kind of
laming that we agreed upon
our openings but i mean he didn't have
to create it
what no i i was i was in he came into my
chat
he came into my chat and i promised no
tricks
yeah we just said nunchucks because um
yeah
so i know you're trying to tell them to
bring something else which would have
been fine honestly
like it's a tournament you can do
whatever you want but he came into my
chat and he's like oh yeah
i'll just play this and this and i was
like okay well i'm going to bring the
baltic and this
and then we can both prep wow this is
i watched a small bit obviously i was
drunk but i watched a few minutes of you
and anna
and anna was showing you had to destroy
me and i was just like wow anna's
supposed to be my teacher and she's like
i'm gonna help
you and i went to the follower account
honestly good business decision good
business yeah good business
no no no no honestly no i'm only joking
but i know by the way anna's anna's so
nice but
you put me under pressure the whole
games and uh i wish
it had ended slightly different than me
blundering the rook but i reckon you're
probably
the favorite to win it so i hope you go
out and win it if i don't get to the
finals and that way i can say i lost to
the winner and i'll be happy
thank you thank you thank you you played
so well actually
um no matter what you prep verse align
if you don't have experience first or at
least me i haven't played against the
caracon very much
so even though i tried to study the
lines it doesn't really matter once the
game actually starts
um so i i felt kind of uncomfortable in
the position and you definitely
you were in my pawn structure you had
everything going i think that first game
was yours
um i just got lucky you missed one thing
i don't know i would have been hard
anyway like it wasn't super open and i'm
not great at converting from there but
yeah it would have been better if i
didn't give the rook away i would have
been the pro play for sure
a year the first game was definitely
brilliant fenton that was probably like
one of the best games i've seen you play
we were very impressed i appreciated we
were every move we were thinking
both of you like played again and again
and especially you fitting in the first
game and
halfway of course the second game was
absolutely incredible
literally yeah daniel went on this big
you know monologue about how it was like
a brilliant game and then like you
you pushed the pawn and the next move
i said this might be the highest quality
game ever played at pogchamps and then
yeah and you've under the real
connection
it's all my fault champs without it
it's it's crazy because the so i'm gonna
ask both of you this uh i'll start with
vincent this time you know you
uh you are right there uh with with
pac-man and you've got a match-up coming
up
so you either make it to the to the
championship bracket or you get bummed
down to the constellation bracket so
what are you thinking right now and you
want to trash talk them the floor is
yours
i don't mind the trash talking we'll get
to that in a moment but like i honestly
did see this as a free roll
everybody has been talking about how
strong hafu is and
has been putting in crazy errors
obviously would have loved
to pull off the upset get the win and to
be guaranteed in the final but in the
back of my mind i kind of knew
that i had the next opportunity that's
why i wanted to rip it open real quick
and just get our like
kings into awkward positions but it just
didn't happen like that but i mean
pacman's good as well but i'll should
talk them
i'm coming for you one of us is going to
be in the loser's bracket it's not
consolation nobody wants to be there
okay
i hope it's you and i hope it's not me
that was
that was beautiful and and how far are
you looking forward to your games and
then your subsequent interviews
with xcc i believe he called david
pakman white shirt walter
um uh i've never interacted with xqc
i've nothing bad to say about him but
it's more i'm just kind of
scared i hope he doesn't he's scared i
hope he's not too mean to me
but i think he'll do well and i have a
lot less pressure
since actually he doesn't have pressure
either huh because
it doesn't matter actually oh that's the
that's the coldest shade ever thrown it
doesn't matter for him
but i mean it doesn't it won't work it
won't affect uh like i still get to go
to winners and he's the
unfortunately doesn't so nicely
it's less pressure from us that's all
what happens if obviously hafiz is a
strong favorite to beat xqc but if i
beat pacman and me and hafu were on the
same points or if
pacman beats me does hafu automatically
go through because she defeated
we both would have two wins oh yeah i
yeah
it's there's there's a whole point
system tiebreaker system
um we we i would love to chat with both
of you
like about chess and life and everything
we we have to let you go we
we really do wish you the best of luck
both against pacman against xuc
for the rest of the tournament amazing
performance thank you for the brilliant
games guys
flawless
[Music]